[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركي
واحييكم وهذه العربيه 360 حيث الخبر من كل
زواياه هو من جميع جوانبه
قنابل عنقوديه ضمن حزمه مساعدات عسكريه
امريكيه لاوكرانيا غدا وموسكو تعتبر
الخطوه تصعيدا
[موسيقى]
طالبان تتاجر بارث امريكا بافغانستان
واتهامات لاداره
بايدنص تقارير عن الانسحاب الفاشل
مباحثات امريكيه صينيه لتجنب سوء التفاهم
وواشنطن تؤكد سعيها لمنافسه اقتصاديه
صحيحه مع الذكي
لدينا ايضا
مشاهير وشركات ومنظمات عالميه ينظمون
وتويتر تهدد بمقاضات متى
[موسيقى]
نرحب بكم مجددا اذا مشاهدينا الكرام ونبدا
قبل ملفات هذه النشره باخر الاخبار
العاجله الوارده على الشاشه عن موضوع
وتويتر
ورساله من تويتر لمتى تقول ان العديد من
موظفي تويتر السابقين لديهم معلومات سريه
ويعملون لدى متى رساله من تويتر لمتى ايضا
نحذركم من اي معلومات سريه يمكن ان ينقلها
موظفون السابقون
ونطالبكم باتخاذ خطوات فوريه لمنع استخدام
اي اسرار تخص التويتر اذا هذا الموضوع
يتفاعل ليس فقط على الصعيد التقني انما ما
هو اكبر من ذلك ايضا رويترز تقول ان شركه
تويتر تهدد بمقاضات متى بسبب تطبيق كما
ذكرنا وموقع سيما فور الامريكيه ينشر
رساله تحذيريه من الشركه من تويتر تحديدا
الى متى التي اطلقت تراتس المنافس للتوتر
بسبب هذا التطبيق بسبب تطبيق الافتراء اذا
هناك عدد من الموظفين في تويتر من
الموظفين السابقين من الذين لديهم معلومات
سريه
ويعملون لدى متى حاليا يتخوف تويتر من ذلك
ويحذر متى من اي معلومات سريه يمكن ان
ينقلها الموظفون السابقون
ومطالبا متى باتخاذ خطوات فوريه لمنع
استخدام اي اسرار تخص تويتر طبعا نحن
لدينا هذا الموضوع ضمن عناويننا الليله
وسنناقشه مع احد المتخصصين في هذه
التقنيات في السلك الفالي في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه تحديدا ولكن بعد ان
نعرض لموضوعاتنا الرئيسيه ونبداها من
تطورات الحرب اوكرانيا اذ قال مسؤولا
امريكيان في تصريحات ان اداره الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن ستعلن عن ارسال مساعدات
عسكريه الى اوكرانيا تتضمن ذخائر عنقوديه
بدوره اكد مسؤول امريكي وفما نقلت عن ه
صحيفه نيويورك تايمز ان اداره بايدن تعتقد
ان القنابل العنقوديه ستكون فعاله في صد
الهجمات الروسيه على اوكرانيا في المقابل
انتقد مندوب روسيا لدى الامم المتحده
فسيلين بنزيا تقارير عن ارسال الولايات
المتحده عنقوديه الى اوكرانيا وقال انها
خطوه جديده نحو التصعيد
القنابل والعنقوديه السلاح المخيف سلاح
محرم دوليا يتسبب باضرار كبيره وقد يستمر
خطره لسنوات طويله فما هي القنابل
العنقوديه نتعرف على ذلك في هذا التقرير
[موسيقى]
معنى من موسكو المحلل العسكري روسيه بابل
اهلا بك معنا سيد بابل الى اي مرحله
ياخذ منح اوكرانيا قنابل عنقوديه الصراع
دائر حاليا او اي صفحه يفتحها في كتاب هذه
الحرب
يبدو ان الامر لن يتعلق بالقنابل
العنقوديه وانما بذخائر عنقوديه لان سلاح
الجو الاوكراني ليس كبيرا وليس لديه
الكثير من القذفات فغالبا ما سيتعلق الامر
عنقوديه توفرها
الولايات المتحده
لصواريخ او لانظمه هاي مارس والتي تطلق
صواريخ يمكن ان تحمل ذخائر عنقوديه وهذا
يمكن ان يوفر لاوكرانيا قدرات اضافيه
وهذا يعني ايضا انه ان الولايات المتحده
بوسعها ان ترسل ذخائر ليست هي بحاجه اليها
وتريد استبدالها
وهي تريد ان تتخلص منها وتفككها وربما قد
يتعلق الامر ايضا ببعض القنابل العنقوديه
فبدلا من تفكيك هذه الاسلحه ودفع
تكاليف ذلك يمكن ارسال هذه اذا خير
الاسلحه الى اوكرانيا لاستخدامها في الحرب
هي طبعا اسلحه فعاله لكنها محظوره بموجب
المعاهدات الدوليه ولا روسيا ولا الولايات
المتحده
ولا اوكرانيا هي اعضاء في المعاهده
الدوليه وبالتالي بالنسبه لهذه الدول هذه
الذخائر والاسلحه هي قانونيه هل يمكن ان
تشرح لنا الفرق لو تكرمت بين القنابل
عنقوديه والذخائر العنقوديه كيف يعني
سيكون اقل ضررا او فاعليه او حجما كمستوى
عسكري ان تمنح اوكرانيا الذخائر وليس
القنابل بما انك فرقت بين الامرين
الامر يتعلق ببعض الخصائص الفنيه
فالامريكيون
لديهم
عجز في الذخائر بسبب الصراع في اوكرانيا
وكثافه
القتال مرتفعه الى درجه تجعل الكثير من
الذخائر قد استنفذت
وصناعه صناعات الدفاعيه في روسيا والغرب
لم تستطع ان تلبي الاحتياجات حسب
ما يسهلك على جبهاته القتال
والذخائر العنقوديه في الغرب
هناك ميل
ليس هناك ميل لاستخدامه وانما يمكن لهذه
الدول ان ترسلها الى اوكرانيا لاستخدامها
وهذا يعني ان هناك عجزه في خائر في
اوكرانيا وسيتم تعويضها بالذخائر
العنقوديه التي لم يتم ارسالها من قبل اذا
الامر يتعلق
باسلحه لا اعتبارات فنيه وطبعا هذا الوضع
سيكون الجميع فيه
منتصرا ولكن هذا بالنسبه للجنود ولكن
بالنسبه للمدنيين هذا خبر السيء للغايه
طيب ولكن استاذ بابل فيما يتعلق
بالتوازن يعني ما الذي يضير روسيا ما دامت
هي متهمه باستخدام هذا النوع من الاسلحه
والعتاد العسكري
في ان تزود امريكا اوكرانيا بذلك انتم
ايضا متهمونه باستخدام هذه المواد وهذه
هذا العتاد وهذه الاسلحه في عملياتكم
العسكريه ما رايك
طبعا هناك اتهامات توجه للجميع وطرف
الصراع تهم بعضهم البعض بشانه الكثير من
الامور ولكن هناك نوع من التوازن في
الاتهامات وكذلك هناك توازن على ارض
المعركه
والقوات الروسيه ولا القوات الاوكرانيه
لها اليد العليا في هذا الصراع على الرغم
من استخدام كميات هائله من الاسلحه وذخائر
لكن الخبر صار هو ان في ظل هذا الاستخدام
الكثيف للذخائر والمعدات العسكريه بنهايه
هذا العام فان الجانبين سوف
يستنفذا كافه الاسلحه وقد يحتاجها لي
مهله او هدنه او وقف لاطلاق النار
ولكنهم يبدو انهم انهم عازما على تدمير كل
شيء فعل ساحه المعركه لتغيير كفه الميزه
ان شاء الله يعني يكون النقص سبب بهدن او
بحذف الطرفين على وقف الصراع في اقرب وقت
شكرا جزيلا لك من موسكو المحل العسكري
الروسي بعض البالغنهاور تحياتي لك
في التطورات الميدانيه افاد مصدر في وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه بان قواتها استهدفت معدات
غربيه ومسلحين ومرتزقه اجانب في الضربه
التي شنتها على غرب اوكرانيا ورجح المصدر
لوكاله المدرعه غربيه في المكان المستهدف
مشيرا الى ان نحو 800 عسكري كانوا
يتمركزون هناك
الى ذلك اكد السكرتير مجلس الامن الروسيني
في بيان له ان كياب شنت هذا العام اكثر من
70 هجوما باستخدام طائرات المسيره على شبه
جزيره القرم مضيفا انه تعرضت اراضي
اقليمات وقصف من قبل القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه واشار باتروشيف في بيانه الى
الاجراءات التي يجب على سلطات المنطقه
الفيدراليه الجنوبيه ان تتخذها وذلك لضمان
سلامه السكان
نناقش لاحقا في العربيه 360 كيف اصبحت
طالبان تتربح من تجاره الاسلحه التي خلفها
الانسحاب الامريكي من افغانستان
[موسيقى]
نفع الرئيس البيلاروسيه وجود قائد مجموعه
فاجنر في اراضي بلاده بعد ان داهم عناصر
من الامن الروسي قصرا لقائد المجموعه في
مدينه
دولارات مع تحف فنيه وترسانه من الاسلحه
اضافه الى جوازات سفر مزوره
[موسيقى]
قبل ان نتابع جديد اخبار رساله تويتر الى
متى التي ظهرت على الشاشه قبل قليل حصلتم
على اسرار تجاريه تخص تويتر بشكل غير
قانوني ولدينا مخاوف من ان الاسرار
التجاريه قد تم استخدامها عن عمد سنناقش
هذا الموضوع لاحقا كما قلنا قبل قليل في
العربيه 360 تتابعون فيها ايضا مقتل جندي
اسرائيلي باطلاق نار قرب نابلس وحماس
تتمنى
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلنت حركه حماس
مسؤوليتها عن اطلاق النار في محيط مستوطنه
تكادومين قرب نابلس بالضفه الغربيه بعد ان
اكد الجيش الاسرائيلي مقتل منفذ اطلاق
النار وقال بيانو للجيش الاسرائيلي انه
جرت تبادل لاطلاق النار بين المنفذ
والقوات الاسرائيليه بالمنطقه بدوره اوضح
مراسل العربيه ان الحادثه اسفر عن مقتل
جندي اسرائيلي واصابه حارس بالمستوطنه
بجروح خطيره
[موسيقى]
قال وزير الخارجيه السوداني والمكلف علي
الصادق ان تاخر الحسم العسكري في السودان
يعود لوجود افراد من قوات الدعم داخل
المرافق الحكوميه والمنازل مؤكدا قدره
الجيش على الحسم العسكري في مدى قصير وزير
الخارجيه السوداني اوضح ايضا ان القوات
المسلحه لا ترغب في انتاج سياسه الارض
المحروقه بالعاصمه والتي تقضي بهدم كافه
المباني التي يختبئ فيها الدعم سريع
قالت قوه الدعم السريعه ان مجموعه افراد
من الجيش السوداني انضموا اليها من سلاح
المهندسين في ام درمان واضافت قوات الدعم
انها لا ترغب في ان تكون بديلا عن القوات
المسلحه وانما ستعمل على بناء جيش مهني
قومي واحد يعبر عن السودان ولا يخضع
لافكار حزبيه بحسب بيان الدعم
اظهرت مقاطع خاصه للعربيه سقوط قذائف في
احياء المعموره جنوب شرق الخرطوم ادت
الاحتراق عدد من المنازل واشتعال النيران
في المنطقه
[موسيقى]
قال متحدث باسم البحريه الامريكيه ان
الحرس الثوريه الايراني يحتاج سفينه
تجاريه في المياه الدوليه بالخليج قد تكون
متورطه في انشطه تهريب واوضحت البحريه
الامريكيه انها رقبت الوضع بشان احتجاز
الحرس الثوري للسفينه دون ان تتدخل
اعلنت بريطانيا فرض حزمه عقوبات جديده
تتضمن 13 شخصا وكيانا بينها قياده دفاع
السيبراني بالحرس الثوري الايراني وقال
وزير الخارجيه البريطاني للعربيه ان سياسه
العقوبات الدائران مستمره حتى يتغير سلوك
النظام الايراني واضاف ان ادراج الحرس
الثوري الايراني على لائحه الارهاب لا
يزال خيارا قائما مشددا على التزام
بريطانيا بمنع امتلاك ايران سلاح النوويا
وفي اللقاء الذي خصم به قل وزير الخارجيه
البريطاني جيمس كليبرلي للزميل ريما مكتب
مديره مكتب العربيه في بريطانيا قال ان
بلاده ترحب بالحوار السعودي الايراني
الهدف لاحلال السلام والاستقرار في
المنطقه مشيرا في الوقت نفسه الى ضروره
وقف امداد طهران
ونامل ان تؤدي المحادثات والاجتماعات التي
اجرتها السعوديه مع ايران الى تغيير في
السلوك ولكن في النهايه الخيار هو للقياده
في طهران اريد رؤيه ايران تتوقف عن تمويل
وتسليح المليشيات المسلحه مثل الحوثيين
واذا كانت هذه المحادثات بين السعوديه
وايران يمكن ان تؤدي الى ذلك فهذا امر
ايجابي ونامل ان تتمكن الصين من ممارسه
تاثير على طهران لمنعها من اتخاذ السلوك
العدواني ضد جيرانها في المنطقه
[موسيقى]
قالت صحيفه
حاولت اخفاء تقريرا تصميم مفصل حول
الانسحاب من افغانستان اظهر انها لم تخطط
جيدا للانسحاب العسكري من هناك اضاف
التقرير ان الاداره فشلت في التبوؤ
بالفوضى في التنبؤ بالفوضى التي تلت
الانسحاب من سقوط العاصمه بياض حركه
طالبان والتخبط في عمليه اجلاء المدنيين
الذي قالت ان اصداره جاء قبل العطله
الطويله لمناسبه عيد الاستقلال على امل ان
يحظى التقرير بالحد الادنى من الاهتمام
قبل ذلك ذكر وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
نشر النسخه الكامله من التقرير لمنع كشف
بعض نقاط الضعف واوجه القصور كما قال
اسلحه خلفها الجنود الامريكيون وراءهم في
افغانستان باتت مصدر ربح لطالبان التي
تبيع وتصدر هذه الاسلحه مجله ان الاسلحه
الامريكيه بدات تظهر في مناطق اضطرابات
بعيده عن افغانستان لتستخدمها الجماعه
المسلحه ضد الولايات المتحده ومصالحها
كشفت المجله عن وجود تجار الحاصلين على
تصاريح من حركه طالبان يقومون ببيع اسلحه
امريكيه الى جانب معدات من روسيا وباكستان
والصين وتركيا والنمسا الشعبيه الاكبر في
الاسواق في هذه الاسواق للبنادق الهجوميه
الامريكيه ومنها التي قد يصل سعر القطعه
الواحده منها الى
2400 دولار والتي تعتبر اكثر تطورا من
بنادق كلاشنكوف على فكره ايضا تسعى
الجامعات المسلحه للحصول على اجهزه الرؤيه
الليليه والتي تباع في افغانستان باسعار
تتراوح بين 500 والف دولار منظمه مرصد
سلام الافغاني اجرت بحثا توصل الى ان
اسواق الاسلحه تنتشر في جنوب وشرق
افغانستان وفي باكستان المجاوره ومنها يتم
التهريب لدول اخرى في تجاره تدور
المليارات من الدولارات وظهرت هذه الاسلحه
مناطق منها باكستان التي يتم فيها استخدام
الاسلحه ضد الجيش الباكستاني او ضد الجيش
الهندي في كشمير ايضا تم الكشف عن وجود
بعض الاسلحه لدى حركات مسلحه كحركات
الشباب في الصومال وافرع داعش في افريقيا
جنوب الصحراء والفلبين اضافه الى غيرها من
الدول وتشير تقديرات وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه الى ان مخزونات الاسلحه
والمركبات المتبقيه في افغانستان بلغت
قيمتها اكثر من سبعه مليارات دولار لكنها
قالت ان الاسلحه كانت بايدي القوات
الافغانيه
صادرت الاسلحه بطريقه مشابهه لتعامرها مع
انتاج الافيون وهو ما يؤدي فقط الى احكام
العرض ورفع الاسعار والفائده الاكبر تبقى
لطالبا
ينضم الينا الان من العاصمه الاخرانيه
كابول عبد الجبار بهير رئيس المركز
الافغاني للاعلام اهلا بك ومن واشنطن
دبلوماسيه الامريكي السابق في افغانستان
وفي دول عديده اخرى وين اهلا بك معنا سعد
السفير اسمحلي سيد بهير ابدا مع ساعات
السفير اولا لاساله عن هذا التقارير الذي
قرانا قبل قليل بعضا من مقتطفاته يتحدث عن
محاوله اداره بايدن اخفاء تقرير رسمي مفصل
الا انه بينت بعض ملامحه هل هذا تعامل
سياسي دبلوماسي يعني حصيف
اعتقد ان كان هناك اخفاء
لهذه التقرير وانما لم يتم نشره وقد تم
نشر التقرير الاخير
من بل وزاره الخارجيه قبل
الاحتفالات
التي جرت المتحده ولكن التقرير بحد ذاته
الصادر عن وزاره الخارجيه صريح تماما
ويشير الى بعض الاوجه القصور في الطريقه
التي
تعملت بها وزاره الخارجيه مع الاوضاع في
افغانستان خلال العام او اكثر من ذلك
الماضي تبقى معنا سعاده السفينه من كابول
الى اي مدى باعتقادك كان هذا يعني اخفاء
متعمدا لمثل هذا التقرير والى اي مد ى
بالفعل
استفادت طالبان من ترك هذه الاسلحه
الامريكيه بغض النظر عن السبب او الطريقه
طبعا
طالبان استولت على كل ما يملكه الجيش
الافغاني من الاسلحه والعتاد العسكري وكان
يعني بطبيعه الحال من من الجيش من من قبل
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لكن ما هو
الواضح هو ان الجيش الامريكي بدا منذ ان
وافق مع الجانب الامريكي مع طالبان
بالانسحاب الامريكي من افغانستان بدا بخطط
لاليه كيف يمكن ان
يسحب معهم العتاد العسكري الذي كان لا لا
يريد الجيش الامريكي ان يعثر عليها سواء
طالبان الافغان او
دول في المنطقه والجوار كذلك لعل كان يريد
ان يخفي كل
التكنولوجيا العسكريه في افغانستان
بالاضافه الى ذلك كان هناك يعني
تدمير الاليات العسكريه في افغانستان كان
هناك مئات
المدرعات دمرت في افغانستان في قواعد
عسكريه
14 في او عشره في في افغانستان سواء في
الجنوب او شمال او العاصمه الافغانيه
كابول هذا قبيل الانسحاب لكن بعض الانسحاب
ليس هناك اي تقارير ان ان اعتاد الذي
يملكه في افغانستان الجيش الامريكي وكان
يعني متطورا ترك لحركه طالبان كل ما بقي
هو كان يعني الاعتاد العسكري الامريكي
الذي قدم الى الجيش الافغاني سواء
المدرعات او او البندقيات او مروحيات وما
الى ذلك
من الجيش الافغاني
ايام النظام السابق قبل حكم طالبان تبقى
مع الولايات دوله عظمى اقوى دوله في
العالم تقود العالم والبعض يعني لا يستطيع
ان يفهم كيف يمكن لاقوى دوله في العالم ان
يعني يكون لديها هذا القصور في في التعاطي
مع دوله بحجم افغانستان عندما تسحب قوتها
هي من اراضيها بعد غزوها واحتلالها
لياخذنا ذلك الى يعني وابل من الافكار
المتعلقه بنظريه المؤامره كيف ترد
وجود تخطيط لكنها تخطيط كان سيئا للغايه
خاصه فيما يتعلق برحيل موظفي السفاره
الامريكيه وكذلك الافغان الراغبين في ذلك
اذا سلسله من الاخطاء وتخطيط
التي ارتكبت وحصل واعتقد هذا يعود
لادارتين وبالنظر الى حجم الاسلحه التي
تركتها الولايات المتحده واستولت عليها
طالبان هذه الاسلحه لم تتركها الولايات
المتحده فقط وانما هي معدات عسكريه سلمت
ايضا للقوات المسلحه الافغانيه عندما
انهارت
طالبان عليها اذا ما نشهده هو سلسله من
نقاط الضعف لدى الولايات المتحده وطبعا
حتى القوه العظمى يمكن ان ترتكب اخطاء
جيسيما ظروف الصعبه ولذلك من الاهميه بما
كان وجود تقارير من هذا القبيل للوقوف على
الاخطاء مفهوم تبقى معنا سعه سفير استاذ
به كيف ترد على نقله محللون افغان
طالبان حضرت ظاهريا تصدير او صادرات
الاسلحه بطريقه مشابهه لتعاملها مع تجاره
الافيون وهذا ادى الى ارتفاع الاسعار والى
يعني فائده كبيره لطالبان
طبعا بعد الانسحاب او او عند الانسحاب
الامريكي اللام مسؤول من افغانستان وسيطر
الطالبان على افغانستان
كان هناك ايادي داخليه بدات باستغلال
الفرصه والحكومه الافغانيه متعهده ولعل
طالبان كذلك
تتعهدت في اتفاق الدوحه للجانب الامريكي
انها لا تكون خطرا ولا تكون مثلا
ضررا على المصالح الامريكيه وانما يكون
افغانستان بلدا تتعامل مع الولايات
المتحده ومجتمع الدولي كبلد مستقل افغاني
كل هذا يعني ان ان ان الحكومه الافغانيه
او طالبان متعهده لان لا تتاجر
باعتاد الوطني لا يحسب هذا انها واعتاد
امريكي نعم هي دعم امريكي للجيش الافغاني
لكن يعتبر عند طالبان وطنيا لكن كان هناك
هناك تهريب الاسلحه في في تلك الفتره خاصه
عند الاصحاب من افغانستان لسحاب الامريكي
وعدم سيطره بشكل
مبائى بشكل يعني اداري كامل لطالبان على
افغانستان كان هناك عده مرات قد قبض على
سيارات تريد تهريب الاسلحه من افغانستان
الى دول ديوان خاصه باكستان
ودول الجوار الاخرى لكن كتعمد
الحكومه الافغانيه
الطالبان تعهدت وتتعهد كذلك انها
وبدات باعاده تصليح كل ما بقي في تلك
الفتره يعني ايام الانسحاب الامريكي وايام
كذلك سيطره طالبان على افغانستان كان هناك
تقارير لوزاره الدفاع الافغاني ان هناك
الاف اكثر من 3000 مدرعات
تم تصليحها في تشكيل او في في اطار لازاره
الدفاع اضافه الى ذلك وزاره الداخليه
وكذلك الامن الافغاني كان لها تقارير انها
بدات بتصليح الاعتاد وانها اعتاد افغاني
والحكومه تتعهد بحفاظها وكذلك استخدامها
لصالحها وليست استخدامها كاداه للضغط او
اداه
للضرر على الاخرين ساعات سفير التقديرات
تقول انه قيمه هذه الاسلحه سبعه مليارات
دولار صحيحا امريكا تقول كانت بايدي
القوات الافغانيه الرسميه التي خسرت امام
طالبان ولكنها قيمه كبيره جدا هل الولايات
المتحده باعتقادك مستعده لفرض عقوبات من
نوع ما على الدول على الاقل التي يثبت
وجود هذه الاسلحه فيها التي لم تبعها
الولايات المتحده اياها او كيف على
الولايات المتحده التصرف الان للحد
يعني حجم الضرر الذي الحقته بهذا الملف
بعد انسحابها الفوضوي والعشوائي من
افغانستان
البعث القلق الاساسي هو اذا ظهرت لاسعلها
بين ايدي الجماعات الارهابيه والجامعات
السعي لاطاحه بالحكومات في البلدان مختلفه
الولايات المتحده كانت واضحه كل وضوح بهذا
الشان فاذا سمحت حركه طالبان
لهذه الجماعات الارهابيه وغيرهم
تنفيذه هجمات انطلاقا من افغانستان فسوف
ترد على ذلك اما بالنسبه لتهريب الاسلحه
فانا متاكد اذا ظهرت هذه الاسلحه في
ترسانات الحكومات التي ليس للولايات
المتحده علاقات معها فطبعا سيتم اثاره
الموضوع مع هذه الدول لكنني لم اسمع اي
نقاش بشان عقوبات تفرد بهذا الشان وفي
المقابل فان العقوبات الخاصه بالجماعات
الارهابيه او المتطرفه اعتقد بوسعك ان ترى
الولايات المتح ده تتصرف في هذا المجال
شكرا جزيلا لك دبلوماسي الامريكي السابق
في افغانستان
وشكرا للاستاذ عبد الجبار بهير رئيس مركز
الافغاني للاعلام ودراسات من كابول تحياتي
اليكما
[موسيقى]
ارتفاع مستوى العنف في فرنسا وباريس
اذا تطورات جديده في موضوع العقوبات وكاله
ايرنا تقول ان طهران تستدعي القائمه
بالاعمال البريطانيه احتجاجا على العقوبات
الجديده نذهب الى فرنسا الان حيث مدد
القضاء الفرنسي حبس الشرطي الذي قتلت
الشاب نائل خلال تفتيش المروري في واقعه
اثاره احتجاجات واعمال شغب استمرت اسبوعا
كاملا قال مصدر مطلع على الملف لوكاله
فرانس ان الشرطيه البالغ ثمانيه عاما
موضوع في الحبس الاحتياطي منذ 29 من شهر
يونيو الماضي بعد توجيه تهمه اليه مؤكدا
ان قرار تمديد فتره الحبس اتخذته غرفه
التحقيق في محكمه الاستئناف في فرنسا
الى ذلك قال مفوض العدل الاوروبيه
ان مستوى العنف مرتفع بشكل واضح في
السنوات الاخيره في فرنسا بما في ذلك
احتجاجات حركه سترات الصفراء وتظاهرات ضد
تعديل النظام التقاعدي واشار في بيانه الى
اعمال الشغب الاخيره التي اعقبت مقتل شاب
نائل برصاص الشرطي من جهتها رفضت وزير
الفرنسيه المكلفه شؤون الاتحاد الاوروبي
كاترين كولو بيانا حول باريس
حده على حد وصفها مشيره الى ان حفظ النظام
العام ليس من ضمن امتيازات الاتحاد
الاوروبي
[موسيقى]
قالت وزيره الخزانه الامريكيه جاني تيالين
بعد وصولها الى الصين ان بلادها ستتخذ
اجراءات لحمايه امنها القومي عند الحاجه
وقالت يلا على تويتر ان زيارتها للصين
التي تستمر لايام هدفها تحسين الاتصالات
وتجنب سوء التفاهم اضافه لتعميق التواصل
بشان مجموعه من القضايا وتبعت يلن ان
الولايات المتحده تسعى الى منافسه
اقتصاديه صحيه مع الصين لصالح العمال
وشركات الامريكيه
اللقاء الاخير بين الرئيس الصيني وجيشه
حمل رسائل عسكريه عده حيث دعا الرئيس
والجيش المتواجده في منطقه في منطقه قرب
الى الاستعداد والتاهب في اي لحظه
من الجيش موجوده في منطقه الى جانب تايوان
الى الاستعداد واشار الى اضطرابات جديده
تعيشها الصين حاليا نتابع
دعوه الى القتال الرئيس الصيني يحث جيشه
على التاهب والجراه زياره تفقديه مفاجئه
لوحده في منطقه متوتره قرب تايوان
رساله توحي بحرب مرتقبه ربما واشاره الى
تحول جذري
دخل العالم فتره جديده من الاضطراب
والتغيير واصبح الوضع الامني في بلدي غير
مستقر وغير واضح ومن الضروري مراعاه
المهام في جميع الاوقات
اوامر عده املاهاشي على جيشه تعميق
التخطيط للحرب والقتال بناء نظام قتالي
مشترك قوي التركيز على التدريب القتالي
الفعلي تسريع تحسين القدرات المفيده
توصيه اخيره ختم بها الرئيس الزياره
الدفاع بحزم على الوطن وامنه
[موسيقى]
نشر موقع عاصمه
الجديد للمنصه الرساله التي ارسلها محامي
لشركه تويتر الى المدير التنفيذي لشركه
متل الملكه لتطبيق
الرساله كانت شديده اللهجه واتهمت مكتب
الحصول على اسرار تجاريه تخصص تويتر بشكل
غير قانوني واكد تويتر في رسالتها الى متى
ان هناك مخاوف من ان الاسرار التجاريه قد
تم استخدامها عن عمد واضفت تويتر ان
العديد من موظفي تويتر السابقين لديهم
معلومات سريه ويعملون لدى متحاليا قد
سربوا تلك المعلومات وحذرت تويتر من اي
معلومات سريه يمكن ان ينقلها موظفون
السابقون كما جاء في المعلومات كما طلبت
بضروره اتخاذ ماده خطوات فوريه لمنع
استخدام اي اسرار تخص تويتر
ما ان اعلن او اعلن عن تطبيق
رسميا حتى اشترك فيه نحو 41 مليون شخص حتى
الان ومن بين هؤلاء اسماء مشاهير من
العالم وشركات عالميه انضمت لهذا التطبيق
الجديد نتابع
[موسيقى]
المولود التكنولوجي الجديد لشركه ميته او
التطبيق الجهنمي الذي اطلقه مارك زوكربيرج
الرئيس التنفيذي للشركه تحت اسم فريدز هو
عنوان منافسه شرسه مع تويتر تدور راحاها
على منصه التواصل
المرحله الاولى من الهجوم على العصفور
الازرق تمت بنجاح ارقام تحمس المستثمرين
على اغلاق باب تويتر وتحويل الوجهه الى
صفوف ميته
التطبيق القاتل والمتاح باكثر من 100 دوله
يشبه تويتر ولكن بميزات تتفوق على تفصيلات
معينه فهو يتيح وضع منشورات نصيه يصل
طولها الى 500 حرف اما روابط المقاطع
المصوره فتتيح تحميل مده تصل الى خمس
دقائق يمكن للمستخدمين الاعجاب بها واعاده
نشرها والرد عليها
هذه المنصه التابعه لميتا تمتاز ايضا عن
التطبيقات المنافسه السابقه بانها تمتلك
قاعده مستخدمين ملياريه وهذا بفضل
انستجرام لان خدمه فريدز جزء من المنصه اي
ان اكثر من مليارين متابع مالهم ان تصلهم
العدوى التكنولوجيه ويحمل ثريدز عاجلا ام
اجلا عيبه الوحيد ان خاصيه التحميل على
سطح المكتب لم تتوفر بعد
القيود التي فرضها ايلون ماسك على مستخدمي
تويتر دفعت المغردين للابتعاد عن قفص
الطائر الازرق فالى اين يتجهون الان
المنصه المنافسه لتويتر شهدت ارتفاعا
كبيرا في اعداد المستخدمين الجدد ولعل
ابرزها الان منصه التابعه لمتى ومع
الابتعاد عن تويتر قامت متى بتسريع اطلاق
التطبيق الجديد الذي بات متوفرا على متاجر
التطبيقات وبحسب متى تقدم المنصه تجربه
جديده ومحسنه للمستخدمين في التواصل
الاجتماعي موقع اخر برز في الاشهر الاخيره
هو ماستوود الذي انتقل له الكثير من
مستخدمي تويتر قبل اشهر بمجرد ظهور
الانباء عن نيه ايلون ماسك الاستحواذ على
تويتر يجينا مؤسس ومدير ماستودون اعلن عن
ان عدد المستخدمين بشكل يومي ازداد بمعدل
يقترب من 300 الف مستخدم مع اضافه 110 الف
مستخدم جديد خلال يوم واحد هو الاول من
يوليو جاريه وبشكل شهري ارتفع عدد
مستخدمين عدد مستخدمي ارتفعوا ب 19 في
يوني و مقارنه بالشهر السابق
من بين المواقع البديله ايضا شبكه بلو
سكاي التي شهدت اقبالا كبيرا من
المستخدمين الجدد ما دفع شبكه الاجتماعيه
لتعليق عمليات التسجيل وانشاء الحسابات
الجديده مؤقتا على ان تستانف عمليات
التسجيل عند حل المشاكل التقنيه ونختم مع
شبكه الاجتماعيه التي تحقق نجاحا كبيرا
ووصلت الى المركز الثاني في قائمه
التطبيقات الاكثر تحميلا على متجر ابل
للتطبيقات مع توقعات بطرح التطبيق لاجهزه
اندرويد قريبا منصه منصه اجتماعيه ترتكز
على مشاركه المحتوى المصور بما في ذلك
الصور والمقاطع المصوره والروابط الى جانب
النصوص وامكانيات انشاء استطلاعات الراي
كما ذكرنا فان المغردين يبتعدون شيئا
فشيئا عن تويتر لكن اللافت ان الكثير من
التطبيقات البديله تم تاسيسها بواسطه
مسؤولين سابقين في تويتر كان من السطاي
بلو سكاي وسبيل
معنى لمناقشه هذا الموضوع عبر سكايب من
عمان الان دكتور حسين العمري خبير
التكنولوجيا المعلومات في سلكنداري اهلا
بك معنا دكتور في العربيه 360 ما الذي
يحصل بين تويتر وبقيه المنصات بعد هذه
الرساله التي قرانا عنها التي واجهتها
تويتر لمته
اول شيء المنصات الثانيه التي ذكرتها
كبديل تويتر هي ليست جديه كلها صغيره
وتعتمد على انها
يعني غير مركزيه فالتحكم فيها ليس من
منطقه واحده وانما كل مكان ربما دوله
وربما جاليه لها تحكم وهذا يتيح لها
الحريه في القوانين ولكن منحت الثقه
والسرعه والاعتماد عليها لن تكون مثل
تويتر او مثل الان فلذلك الارقام التي
ذكرتها لهم كلها يعني 100 الف خلينا
التطبيقات الثانيه بس الرساله الرساله
تحديدا هلا تويتر عم بيقول انه في موظفين
سابقين عنا عم يشتغلوا بمتى وربما سربوا
اسرار لديهم اياها اسهمت في انشاء هذا
التطبيق تطبيق شو المسموح من اللي مش
مسموح الان
اذا سمعت
وصعب اثباته عاده يكون دقيق ومحاكم ولكن
ما
طارت التوقيت القاتل لاصدار ثلاث توقيت
الصراحه ممتاز جدا
ويضمن ان الناس ستبتعد عن تويتر الناس
كانت تتابع تويتر من اجل المشاهير
المشاهير نصفهم للاخبار نصفهم
للانتر له وتلكهم مثلا للبراندات وشركات
لكن
الصحابيين كبار الشياطين الكبار والمفتوحه
مش ضروري تكون صديق عنده فالان هؤلاء
بداوا في التحويل مثلا كم كارديشيان
كان اول ناس حولوا مثلا على على
رونالدو وغيرها حيكونوا اول ناس فالناس
تتبعهم
شو اللي عم تسميه الان اسرار تجاريه تخص
تويتر
حصلت عليها متى بشكل غير قانوني كما قالت
الرساله رساله من تويتر الى متى وان هناك
مخاوف من ان هذه الاسرار التجاريه قد تم
استخدامها عن عمد
وين الموضوع اللي ممكن يدخل فيه القضاء
هذه الاشياء انا يعني رجل مطلع على
البراءات اللي اخترعها وعندي الحمد لله
ودخلت في قضايا محاكم شاهد من شركات وغيره
فهذه المواضيع طويله الامد وصعب اثباتها
بيوم الليل وسيكون يعني
سيكون هناك تحول جارف قبل ان تدخل هذه حتى
الى المحاكم يعني لن يكون هناك قرار
فدرالي بمنع مثلا
سند من الانتشار السند يعني لها قاعده
شعبيه ملياران من الانستقرام انت ثاني شيء
سهوله التحويل انت تستطيع تحول فقط من
حسابك في الانستغرام من غير ان تبلع
بيانات
وغير خصوصيه نفسها يعني ميته عملت شيء
جميل انها عندها قاعده مشتركه لكل
تطبيقاتها الواتساب والانستجرام والفيسبوك
والان تريد عندها 3 مليار على فيسبوك
عندها مليارات على واتساب وعلى انستجرام
ومليار على الماسنجر فه
[موسيقى]
لهم متابعين جدا الرياضيون يعني
رونالدو ولا الفنانات عندك اكثر ناس عندهم
يعني
شوف انت لما تكون متعاون مع محل وتشتري
منه ويفتح محل ثاني جنبه لاي شيء ثاني حتى
تروح معه لانه عندك ثقه في هذا المكان
يعني لو شركه ثانيه فتحت نفس الثريد لن
تحصل على اربعين مليون 30 مليون في 24
ساعه 40 يعني مليون وربع هل هل المعركه
وصلت يعني هل معركه جيولوجيه الان باي
معنى من المعاني فكريه ثقافيه او تقنيه
ماديه محض
انا اراهم كلهم في التضييق شبه بعض يعني
تقول انها ستكون مقيده اكثر على العري
مثلا والاباحيه وعلى الكراهيه يعني اذا
خطاب الكراهيه
فتكون اضيق من تويتر يعني ولكن صراحه كلها
عمليه ماليه وسيطره واستحواذ فهو تنافس
على البزنس يعني تنافس على المالي ولكن
ناحيه الاخلاق ولا نار يعني ليست هناك
فروق كبيره ولكن نشط يعني لا تدعمه منظومه
في هذه الاشياء جاي وتخبط وترك الرئاس وحط
شريط جديد الرئيس الجديد لم يعين لم يحدد
ماذا سيفعل بتويتر يعني الان تويتر معرض
للانهيار بالمره او انه يتدارك نفسه
ويستطيع الحفاظ على نصف من عنده على الاقل
فيعتمد على انا اتابع صحفيين كبار جدا
وغيرهادات وكذا
تشوف اراء الناس وغيرها المشاهير اتابع
الرياض مثلا هناك فهؤلاء اذا حولوا على
الثنتين انا ساختار
ثلاث لانه انا عندي انستقرام واطالع انه
لا اكتب عليه لكن اتابع وعندي فيسبوك تمام
لنرى ما الذي ستبدي الايام القادمه في هذا
الصراع ولكن بدون شك انه صراع شيق جدا
شكرا جزيلا لك من عمان العمري الخبير في
تكنولوجيا المعلومات في سيليكون فالي
تحياتي اليك
[موسيقى]
التصريح اليوم في العربيه 360 عن عضويه
السويد في حلف الناتو التي باتت قريبه
المنال انها تصريحات امين عام الحلفيان
يبدو انه يعول على اللقاء الذي اي مخطط
لعقده بين الرئيس التركي ورئيس وزراء
السويد الاثنين
روايتان وانفجار اما الحقيقه فغائب على
الاقل حتى الان هذه ليست العاب الناريه او
تاثيرات اضيفت الى فيلم سينمائي بل هي
لقطات تظهر المشهد في مكيفكا تلك المدينه
الواقعه في اقصى الشرق الاوكراني
انها استهدفت التشكيله المسلحا روسيا اما
موسكو فتحدثت عن مقتل مدني واصابه اخرين
جراء قصف اوكراني على المدينه الخاضعه
للسيطره الروسيه
هكذا نصل الى ختام العربيه 360 لكن اخبار
الساعه لا تنقطع وتتابع فيها سهام بن
زاموش الان سهام اهلا بك مكان احلالك
الصبح يا سهام بقيت ضليتي الصبح احسن اهلا
بك سنناقش اليوم اخبار الساعه توجه اداره
بايدن ارسال قناه العنقوديه الى اوكرانيا
و ايلون ماسك يهدد بمقتضاه المنصه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات